from nbc sports we always talk ponies
and pucks with this man and
yep we've got uh the second round of the
nhl playoffs continuing tonight
and then tomorrow on nbc the final leg
of the triple crown the belmont stakes
from the great
city of new york eddie ulchuk joining us
here on the rich island show how are you
eddie oh
hey rich nice to be with you how you
been uh very well thanks thanks for
having me yeah great time of year
usually uh and again all of our worlds
have been upside down here the last
little while but usually we'd be in
probably about game three or four into
the stanley cup finals right
considering the season started a little
bit later and uh here we are
you know just at the start of round two
so a great time of year and then you
mentioned uh a little over 24 hours from
now
we'll have the belmont so usually i'm on
the coverage for nbc
in person but since i got the assignment
of uh and i'm very happy with it
the assignment of colorado and vegas i'm
in vegas right now getting ready for
game three tonight so
lots lots to like lots lots of action
going on both on and off the ice
well especially since eddie i i remember
when we talked
last year at this time when the show was
on nbcsn
uh you were in a hotel room you were
quarantining right
right i was in the bubble i was in the
bubble up in edmonton yeah it was four
days
without leaving my room and uh in order
to be able to do my job properly and
i got through the four days and we got
through the stanley cup finals in a
bubble and here we are
down to eight teams rich and uh it's
hard to believe i mean considering
you know everything uh that the league
is elegant all the leagues but in
particular the national hockey league
with the protocols and everything and
yeah they've had a couple of uh they had
a couple of hiccups this year towards
the end of the year especially with
vancouver but you know vegas had a
little bit of a problem and look it's
not
you know the national hockey league and
players and teams and essential
part of the organizations are not immune
to this covet world that we're living in
so we found a way to get through the
regular season and
here we are down to the final eight so a
tip of the hockey helmet to the
commissioner mr bettin and bill daley
and
all the people involved because i think
the entertainment value has been through
the roof so far
so far in these playoffs so um i guess
uh
where it they put all the canadian teams
in
in one part of the bracket um
which you know which means we were
definitely going to get a canadian team
playing for a conference championship
which gotta
uh you know at least you know i i i
guess certainly here in los angeles the
curse of marty mcstore
mcsorley's stick uh might finally be
somehow someway rectified uh or
exercised by the team that
that started it all what do you think of
a chance of of a canadian team making
the cup finals here handicap everything
for me
from that side of the ledger moving on
eddie well look at i mean you had the
teams that finished third and fourth
respectively in the canadian division in
winnipeg and montreal take out the
edmonton oilers and the toronto maple
leafs and
i mean for me at the end of the day i
mean it comes down to being able to to
put somebody away right like toronto had
the canadians upright three games to one
and the maple leafs weren't able to do
it in in game five and they gave the
canadians an opportunity to go back home
and then you get to a game six and all
of a sudden it's a game seven and
the pressure is certainly on the home
team look i would want on game seven
in my own building all the time i mean i
only can speak from experience of being
a member of the new york rangers in 94
when we had to come back home and play
not only
in the uh conference final uh or the
yeah the conference finally get by the
devils in double overtime in a game
seven but also win the stanley cup
against seven but the maple leafs
weren't able to do it
the haves of montreal canadians look at
they got a big team they got a heavy
team they've got a great goaltender and
carrie price i mean they're starting to
score goals now
and winnipeg's a team that took out
arguably the two two of the top five
players we have in the league in round
one so
okay i thought it was a flip of a point
going in i saw the way montreal played
winnipeg loses mark scheifele who got
suspended for four games for the big hit
on jake evans at the end of the game
that's a huge huge loss for the winnipeg
jets
but they've been a team that's been able
to find ways to win games here
with uh with a defense that maybe isn't
maybe up to
maybe top 12 or 15 the entire national
hockey league when you talk about the
defensive core
but hey you can take down and limit
edmonton and scoring goals in round one
why can't they do it against the team in
my opinion that's offensively
challenging montreal so i still give
winnipeg
a puncher's chance here to get to the
conference final all right then who wins
it all because i uh
well i got like at the start of the year
i'm not going to be so like some of my
colleagues and change
seven times over the course of this
season so for the record i picked
colorado with the start of the year i
thought it would be a colorado carolina
final
uh i'm still alive on that one uh but
colorado look at they probably in in
game two back home against vegas
the better team uh was the vegas golden
knights and
give philip gruber the goal center for
the abs a lot of credit rich he played
really well in the second third period
in overtime and then eventually
in overtime they got a power play that
being colorado and renton scored
they're up two games tonight so look at
the series could easily be one one vegas
is still in it right but it's a must win
for the dtk tonight there is no doubt
about it they have to win this game they
cannot go down three nothing
uh against colorado i mean if you can't
beat eddie elcheck here uh from nbc
sports on the rich eisen show
so if you can't be at the actual
racetrack if you can't be
at the belmont uh what better town to be
here than las vegas nevada for you to be
able to
maybe um find it find i think you could
find a place right
oh yeah i like it i got my feet up at
the beautiful red rock resort hotel
i've been coming here for 17 years and i
will have a great seat tomorrow
considering i am not working tomorrow
okay uh i get my feet up all day
tomorrow to be able to watch the belmont
and i
i promise you i will wear out a path
from my seat
to the wagering window at the red rock
or my express vet account will get us
certainly an overwork on tomorrow well
all i'm saying all i'm saying uh ed is
we're on uh raider nation radio 9 20 am
in las vegas
uh i think you just got your meal comped
uh by dropping the
units look at rich hey i've been going
there for a long time i was there
well before anybody knew about the
beautiful red rocks so you know what i
can't wait to get there okay
looking forward to a great weekend you
think of the belmont yes what do you got
a mile and a half
eight horse field i think the horse
probably end up being the favorite and
it's going to be hard to go against a
favor in my opinion
is the two horse essential quality he
was a favorite in the kentucky uh
using the kentucky derby he ran forth
that day
i didn't i didn't like him i thought he
really ran his heart out the race before
i thought he left his derby race on the
track in the race before it came in
about a month before
he's bred to run a mile and a half a lot
of these horses as you know rich won't
run a mile and a half the rest of their
life
but this horse is bred to do it before
he lost it the derby and finished four
he was a perfect he was five for five in
his career
two-year-old champion i think he'll get
the perfect set up
now two to one five to two you know
not not great odds but sometimes you got
to take what the track gives you so
for me it's all about the two horse
essential quality and horse that won the
preakness the three horse
rombauer so i'm gonna play a little two
three three two box
but all my money is going to be on the
nose of essential quality tomorrow is
that the chardonnay people the three
horse
ron bauer is that what that is uh yeah
no it is not but
certainly uh they've had a few uh
they've had a few from pointing the
preakness i will say that okay i mean
i'm just taking a shot there because if
you just you know keep mentioning the
name of the uh
resort that you're in you're trying to
get your room comp i'm trying to get at
least
uh some great chardonnay sent to the
rich eisen show um
so what what is your take on what
happened with baffert and
and baffert saying that the racing
community was so upset about it
and now here we are it took it took
literally forever and a day like let's
just say if
if uh if baseball the nfl or any any
major sport
had suspended somebody due to a drug
test and it took
a million years essentially right and
actually you you
started you you put you put the athlete
back
out there to run to or to compete in
a nationwide internationally watched
event
people go what the hell's going on so
what what is your take on all of what
happened
look it's interesting we talk about that
rich because if you go back a couple of
years ago
uh when maximum security the horse that
finished the
derby line the finish line first at the
derby a couple of years ago and then was
disqualified for interference on the
turn uh coming from home uh maximum
security in his jockey uh
um louis
he got he got in trouble for the ride in
that race and he got
they call him days so he you know he got
technically suspended for
a handful of days but he appealed that
the appeal did not he'd never served
those days until
a year after a year after
so to me this is there's there's a lot
there look at there's a lot of problems
uh in in a lot of areas and horse racing
but to me that that's just one of them
right like look at like
again it costs money to get these tests
back the due process
every state has different uh rules
let me just make this perfectly clear is
that the this the substance that was
found
in medina spirit the horse that won the
kentucky derby
it is not a banned substance it is
allowed
up to a certain amount now the horse
tested
the amount that was in there was over
the allotted uh
amount that's on bob baffert that's on
his team he has to wear that
uh it's been a cloud over the sport for
for a while
and and now with the split sample coming
back and churchill downs now
you know banning him for the next couple
of years bob baffert has to wear that
and that's the way that it is but again
i think that
initially and even through this whole
process is when you hear
you know a failed drug test everybody
just assumes this is something that is
not
allowed in horse racing uh if you want
to take it to the next level instead of
testing just
the the five uh you know the five horses
uh the top five finishers after the
kentucky derby
test them all when you go to the
pre-race testing
why aren't they testing for everything
instead of just certain things like
again
there's there's so many things here but
most importantly ask me about bob
baffert
he has to wear this it's obviously
disappointing but again i want people to
know the facts is that the substance
that was found in the horse that won the
kentucky derby
is not a banned substance the amount
that he had in a system was
over the allotted limit here's the
example rich if that test was taken
in california he would have not there
would have been no red flag there would
have been no
failed test in churchill bounds it's
different but again
that is on bob baffert to make it
perfectly clear and
and that's something that he's going to
have to live with and uh and hopefully
be better for and i think that he will
he's been the face
of the sport for a long long time and uh
and this certainly isn't great for the
game but
to me there's a lot more to uncover in
in in our game in horse racing
uh than than just what has taken place
with the kentucky derby and
i will say this last thing is that when
you see racetrack starting to
ban uh you know bob baffert coming to
their track or not allowing to race here
or there or whatever it is it's like
okay well is that going to be the
consistent line rich
are you going to sit there and go well
wow if eddie roll check has a
as a positive test or he has had a
positive test
are you going to ban him as much so
those are the questions i think are
being answered on the on the inside of
horse racing is look if you're gonna do
this the bob baffert
just because it was a kentucky derby
well then you better be doing it to the
seven or eight guys or
or women that are training horses right
now at your racetrack are you going to
suspend them as well moving forward
so again everybody has a due process bob
had that and unfortunately uh it came
back
uh what the test said after the first
time and uh and hopefully uh the game
will be better for it
ed uh enjoy tonight's proceedings on
nbcsn puck dropping at ten eastern time
right there in las vegas nevada
uh colorado versus the vegas golden
knights
and then tomorrow uh the belmont which
you will be watching where are you going
to be watching it again
ed where are you going to be watching
beautiful red rock resort and casino
in las vegas oh god yeah and chris brock
been asking the question you just got on
my ear this is this could be the most
important question i've got no eddie
i know you're gonna box the two three
and the exact but can we throw in like a
third horse for the trifecta what do we
got yeah you know um
let's go uh man i don't know if hot rod
charlie can get the distance uh known
agenda maybe can suck up with their
light you know what
there's a hockey tie there known agenda
owned by vinnie and teresa viola
they also own the florida panthers so
let's let's let's let's throw the hockey
tie in there pucks and ponies rich as
you brought me on okay uh pucks and
ponies going out so let's go
two three and i believe known agenda i
don't have it in front of me i believe
known agenda is the six horse and then
you know if
if they don't win we'll just rip up the
tickets and say the name van beesbrook
you know and just throw it down on the
ground or or you know what just uh just
charge it to my room over at the
restaurant
the under hills right take it
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here